Every December, neighbors
all over the country
have their yearly Christmas
light pissing contest,
outdo each other.
Which is just what you want
around a bunch of power strips.
And there are photos
of these retina-burning,
holiday hellholes
all over the web.
So I'm gonna show you some bad
Christmas lights
and for 250 points,
just answer a few questions
about them.
Very simple. No big deal,
just a few questions.
Are you nervous?
You seem nervous.
Why are you so nervous?
You shouldn't be so nervous.
I'm not accusing you
of anything.
Anyway, let's get started.
But you do seem
a little nervous.
All right, let's start
with the lights
that kind of remind me
of something,
but I can't quite...
picture it.
(laughter)
I just...
Reggie.
What is going on here?
If-if-if you build it,
it will come.
HARDWICK:
Yeah, points. Very good.
-Very good.
-(cheers and applause)
That's cute.
It's from, uh, field of creams.
Uh, James Adomian.
Clearly the happiest ending
of the year.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points. Very good.
Morgan.
He's celebrating
that special time of year
when your dick gets infected.
-HARDWICK: Oh, points.
-ADOMIAN: Ah.
HARDWICK:
Oh, boy.
I am appalled.
Here we are doing a family
Christmas show,
and you-- all you guys
saw were pe--
This is clearly Sideshow Bob.
I can't believe how filthy
all of you are.
You had to take it down
into the pants.
Next, here comes Santa Claus.
And before we start this one,
keep your eye on the angel,
all right?
♪
(laughter)
(cheering and applause)
What's a Christmas carol you
might sing about this tableau?
James Adomian.
The little hummer boy.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
♪ I blew his horn for him
♪ A-rump-a-pum-pum
♪ Please don't neglect
the balls ♪
-♪ A-rump-a-pum-pum
-ADOMIAN: ♪ A-rump-a-pum-pum
♪ A-rump-a-pum-pum.
Morgan Murphy.
Uh, Silent Night,
'cause if you tell your parents
I'll kill them.
HARDWICK (laughing):
All right.
Points.
Next one.
Here's ol' Piss Kringle.
There he is.
Looks like he's having
a good time.
What's Santa celebrating,
Morgan Murphy?
He's celebrating getting off
a nine hour flight.
HARDWICK:
All right. Points.
-Yeah, yeah.
-(laughter)
(cheers and applause)
I would.
Next up this Noel hell.
(audience exclaiming)
Oh, Jesus Christ.
A lot of yard displays
have a theme.
What is the theme
of this yard display?
James Adomian.
It looks like we've lost
the water on Christmas.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
Points, yeah.
Morgan.
That is, uh, Trump's
holiday internment camp.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
(cheers and applause)
That's stupid.
Next, the morning
after Christmas
when everybody is drained.
There they are.
What happened here?
Reggie Watts.
It looks like a bunch of
inflatable Christmas ornaments
-got deflated.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-Points.
-(laughter)
A little unclear.
Morgan.
Okay, it's gonna be a little
funnier than Reggie's.
(laughing)
It's, uh, uh, Santa Claus
is coming to Jonestown.
HARDWICK:
All right. Points.
Points. Very good.